so when I was dating then I just truly
didn't understand how awful I was being
until I became a man and then I was like
oh I was making so many things crazy for
no [__] for example whoa like a
confidence thing too right it's the way
women are positioned in society we are
taught to attach ourselves to men and
that's where our value comes from now
you can talk a lot [__] oh no that's not
the case but at its core it is the case
it is the case and so so much of you is
reflected in the God and the God and he
has so much power I mean you lose all
your status if you guys stop being in
your existence in a way I didn't realize
how powerless I was actually feeling in
that position and you were probably
acting out because you fell powerless
right if you leave me I lose everything
so I got to be on your ass so I don't
lose everything yes the the jealousy the
smothering often comes from this idea
that their identity is wrapped into who
the guy is yeah and maybe women don't
even understand no they don't because
natural thing